hello and welcome to the agenda this
week we're in Brussels what next week
will see us back in Strasbourg for the
last plenary before the summer break he
is a few of the highlights started
things off is the Federalists the man
that David Cameron couldn't kick to the
curb Commission president-elect
jean-claude Juncker this week he's been
making his case to any peas in Brussels
his vision includes making Europe number
one in the renewable energy market
strengthening foreign policy and just in
case David Cameron felt a bit left out
he says he's open to negotiating
Britain's relationship with the EU mr.
Yong Kim makes a final speech to any
Peas at the plenary followed by a vote
to rubber-stamp Ethan ointment on
Tuesday over to t tip the us-eu trade
investment partnership that the
Commission wants to use to boost
economic recovery in Europe buying
closed doors negotiations have been
taking place to try and get the deal off
the ground but could the new Parliament
put a spanner in the works despite
guarantees to protect public services
critics aren't convinced since before
the elections right and left-wing
parties have talked of blocking the deal
m EPS will debate its merits following a
statement from the Commission on Tuesday
no job no hope the exact figure on the
number of young people unemployed across
Europe may not be something committed to
memory but their problems can't be
escaped Emmie peas are set to debate and
pass the resolution on new measures to
get young people moving in the right
direction could a European employment
insurance scheme be an idea for the
future find out more on Wednesday how
much time you get off for maternity
leave depends on the country you live in
in Belgium for example you get 15 weeks
off at eighty-five percent of your
salary over in the UK it's 52 weeks and
up to ninety percent of your salary
harmonization was called for to get
better rights for mothers and fathers
but on Tuesday there'll be a debate on
the withdrawal of the maternity leave
directive so what went wrong apparently
it costs too much for member states see
what happens in the debate on Tuesday
and a quick mention of Iraq and Ukraine
with violence evening in both countries
MEP s will sit down to discuss what they
can do to how
find out more next week and that's all
we have for this agenda take care and
enjoy the week